هذا المكان سري جدا
يحاوطه الغموض قبل ان تحوطه الحراسه
الامنيه المشدده
يستعصي على اعتى عصابات السرقه حول العالم
الاف من الجنود وانظمه الامان شديده
التعقيد تجعل من المستحيل اختراقه انه
مبنى خزانه سبائك امريكا الذهبيه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منا
عالم غريب
هذه قلعه فورت نوكس الواقعه في ولايه
كنتاكي الامريكيه بين اسوارها يقع قبول
سري من الذهب ما لا تستوعبه عقول
البشر
على مدخله كتبت عباره الذهب لا يقاوم في
اشاره الى اهميه قيمه ما يحويه هذا القبو
اهلا بكم في الخزانه الرئيسيه الاحتياطي
الذهب في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
قرع طبول الحرب العالميه الثانيه قررت
الاداره الامريكيه حفظ ثرواتها من الذهب
خشيه ان ياتي ذلك اليوم الذي تنهب فيه عام
وبامر من الرئيس فرانكلين روزفيلد تم
تشييد هذا المبنى بكلفه بلغت نحو نصف
مليون دولار وقتها وعلى مساحه 110 الاف
فدان كميه
الجرانيت المستخدمه انذاك بلغت نحو 16 الف
قدم مكعب ونحو
750 طما من حديد التسليح
و670 طما من الفولاذ الهيكلي
رغم تلك الاطنان من الخرسانه المسلحه
والحديد والفولاذ الا ان المساحه الفعليه
للقبو السري كانت بحجم شقه عاديه مكونه من
نحو اربع غرف تلك الغرف بها عشرات
المقصورات موزعه على طبقتين تم ختم كل
منها بشريط خاص مصمم لاظهار ماء اذا كان
قد تم الدخول القصري قبل ذلك ام لا وهي
تضم نصف الاحتياطي الاستراتيجي من الذهب
للولايات المتحده اي ما يزيد على اربعه
الاف طن من المعدن الاصفر تستطيع الولايات
المتحده ان تفخر بكونها اول حارس للذهب في
العالم مع ثمانيه
الاف133 طنا من الاحتياطي اي اكثر من ضعف
الكميه التي تملكها المانيا التي تحتل
المرتبه الثانيه في التصنيف
تلك الكميه الهائله من الذهب استدعت حراسه
مشدده وبالغه التعقيد لدرجه ان اعتى
عصابات السرقه لن تتمكن من اختراق الجدر
الامنيه هناك فالقبول يقع ضمن منطقه تابعه
للجيش الامريكي واكثر من 30 الف جنديا
مدججين بالسلاح في فورت نوكس اضافه الى
مروحيات من طراز اباتشي من دون طيار ومئات
من اجهزه الانذار وكاميرات الفيديو وحقول
الالغام والاسلاك الشائكه والكهربائيه كل
ذلك يستحيل اختراقه ومن يستطع فعل
المستحيل سيصطدم بهيكل القلعه الحصين
وزن باب القلعه يبلغ نحو 20 طنا وهو يشكل
واقيا قويا من الانفجارات في الداخل يوجد
ثلاثه موظفين ياتون من اجهزه مختلفه من
البنك لفتح الاقوال الثلاثه لكل خزنه كما
ان جميع الخزائن لديها نفق سري للهروب
عبر تاريخ هذا المكان لم يفتح لاحد ولم
يخضع لاي لجنه تفتيش او مراقبه الا في عام
74 عندما قام وفد من الكونجرس بعمليه
تفتيش وقتها سار تحت الارض عبر نفق ادى
بهم لهذا الجهاز الدائري الفولاذي دار
دورته وكشف عن هذا المشهد كهف الكنوز